budgets are always tricky to navigate
this one especially so with the brexit
as a backdrop and the Prime Minister's
promise to end austerity so when I sat
down with Chancellor he told me that the
budget he'll be outlining tomorrow
assumes there will be a brexit deal and
if there isn't there will have to be a
new budget and a change of direction for
the economy but I started by asking if
austerity is really coming to an end and
if so what that actually means the Prime
Minister has said that once we get the
deal done with the European Union and we
can look to the future and the spending
review that we will do next year we will
be able to show the British people that
their hard work has paid off and that we
will be able to continue getting our
debt down because that's an essential
thing to do but also be able to provide
a bit more support for our public
services in the future so it could be
more spending well I think people
recognize that there has been enormous
pressure on the public services as we've
dealt with the aftermath of Labour's
recession rebuild our public finances
but we are now at a turning point our
debt is falling the public finances are
performing better and people now want to
know that there is a little bit of
relief coming down the line but I would
say this I don't think that this is only
about public services it's also about
real wages people want to feel that
their real wages are going to grow year
after year after year that they can plan
ahead on the basis of that real increase
in incomes and living standards and they
also want to know that whatever we do
with the public services isn't just
being done by taxing them more that they
will actually be able to keep more of
their hard-earned wages to spend on the
things that matter to them and their
families
you were talking about these spending
review next year and about the deals so
it would it be right to assume then that
the end of austerity isn't going to be
coming in the budget it's going to be a
bit of a longer project
well the Prime Minister referred to the
spending review next year because in
terms of public services that is when we
will set out our plans for spending over
the next few years in the normal way
what I will do in the budget tomorrow is
set out
broadly a spending envelope going
forward but the detail will be for the
spending review because that's when we
quite properly look at the envelope of
money available and decide collectively
what our priorities are for the next few
years that to me is the responsible way
to budget first of all you work out how
much money you've got and then you
decide what your priorities are for
spending it and the problem you've got
isn't it that people aren't going to
feel like austerity is actually ending
unless they can see it having an impact
in their lives and things have been
difficult I've used as you've said you
know since 2010 school budgets down
eight percent twenty thousand fewer
police in England and Wales the welfare
Secretary's admitted that universal
credit will leave some people worse off
these people aren't going to believe you
when you say there's light at the end of
the tunnel unless you address some of
these things well school spending is
protected in real terms party engine
sixteen police funding we protected in
the 2015 spending review settlement but
I accept that public services have been
under pressure they've made enormous
efforts to deliver efficiency doing more
with less and people do want to know
that we've reached a turning point where
we can provide more support for our
public services but don't don't forget
we've already made and I can I can talk
about this because it's not a secret in
the budget we've already made the most
important budget announcement back in
June that we're going to put 80 plus
billion pounds over the next five years
into the NHS so over 20 billion pounds a
year of additional real terms money by
the end of this forecast period
transformational investment I noticed
said that you talked about the NHS you
talked about schools who talked up the
police you didn't talk about universal
credit and actually for some of those
people who are going to be worse off the
most vulnerable people in society many
of them they're not going to feel like
austerity is ending according to the
resolution foundation three million
working families losing 2,500 pounds a
year a 50% rise in people using food
banks in areas where Universal Credit
has been rolled out I mean you know
putting the covert accountants sort of
owns a society do you understand what
it's like for those people so univer
Universal Credit is a very important
innovation the legacy benefit system
that we operated for years left millions
of people stranded out of work unable to
work they'd have made themselves worse
off by going into work what Universal
Credit does is ensure that everybody is
supported to move into work and that
they are always better off in work so
it's a very important structural reform
but if you are a parent it was going to
a food that because you can't work out
how to give food on the table so you can
understand why that might feel like the
kind of back I can't exactly so let me
finish the point so I think that
Universal Credit is a very important
innovation and once it's rolled out
people will see that it's a much better
way to run a welfare system but there
have been issues around the transition
from legacy benefits into Universal
Credit many of the kind of problems that
you're talking about occur when people
move from one system into the other and
there's a mismatch in the way the
systems work I've already put over two
billion pounds into over the last two
budgets into smoothing that transition
you know we continue well we continue to
look at how this process is working and
if if we find cliff edges and
difficulties frictions in in the move
from the old benefit system to Universal
Credit then of course we'll always try
to smooth those out and and be pragmatic
about this and now I know that you're
looking at investing in roads for lots
of people getting potholes on their
Street or a very visible sign of
austerity so what are you planning on
doing well I am going to make some more
additional money available for local
authorities to deal with urgent repairs
potholes in roads repair work on bridges
these are small projects in themselves
but they make a huge difference to
people and actually they make a huge
difference to the efficiency of the road
system overall so this is money well
spent
well in
but more widely we have to look at
investment in our roads and I will be
making an important announcement about
the hypothecation of vehicle excise duty
so that it is all spent on funding our
strategic roads Network for the future
that's an important investment in
Britain's productivity I'm also
interested in your plans for the high
string and
debenhams announcing that 50 stores are
closing just the latest retailer to
really come under under pressure and I
kind of help think sometimes that we
talk a lot about subsidizing some
industries you know the steel industry
the banks but for lots of people the
high street is absolutely at the heart
of their community so do you recognize
that any penny won't do anything about
it so I absolutely recognize that the
high street plays a critical role in
many communities but we have to
recognize as well that the change that's
driving the the the evolution of our
high street can't be put back in the
bottle the British have taken to online
shopping like no other nation on earth
and for better or for worse we have to
recognize that that is happening so our
high streets have to change we want to
protect them because we want them to
remain at the heart of our communities
but we can't do that by freezing the
model of 10 or 20 years ago in a spec it
won't work so we've got to help the high
street to evolve and the high street of
the future frankly will have fewer
retail outlets and more leisure
destinations more food and drink outlets
I expect that high streets of the future
will be smaller with more of the
peripheral areas around them redeveloped
as how seems like business rates or
online transaction taxes yeah of course
we'll look at the ways in which we can
help to smooth this process but it's
very important that we recognize that
the high street will have to change ID
jinkin we can support the high street as
it changes but we can't prevent that
change from happen where do you shop
Guildford usually which has a actually a
very nice high street but are you an
online shop as well do you use I am an
online shopper I do yeah yeah yes and
now I'm also keen of course talk about
breakfast because this is really you
know the back
drop for your budget and you've been
pretty only honest about some of the
consequences of not getting a deal and
ten percent for example can come from
GDP if that happens so if there isn't a
deal will you still be unable to end or
starting well I'm very confident that we
will negotiate a deal with the European
Union and the main element of that deal
has to be that we continue to have
frictionless access to European markets
or reciprocal it if you don't get what
you want will you be able to end
austerity if there isn't if we don't get
a deal if we were to leave the European
Union without any deal I think that's an
extremely unlikely situation but of
course we have to prepare and plan for
all eventualities as any prudent
government would if we were to find
ourselves in that situation then we
would need to take a different approach
to the future of Britain's economy we
would need to look at a different
strategy and frankly we'd need to have a
new budget that set out a different
strategy for the future unless an D the
the the approach that I'm going to be
setting out tomorrow is based on the
assumption as is the OB R's report of a
a deal being done with the European
Union and us continuing to be able to
trade on reasonable terms with our
closest neighbors in Europe so I'm just
- just to really try and get to the gist
of what you're saying if there isn't a
deal which I know you don't want and
would there be less money for government
departments what austerity continue well
there would be certain we would have to
wait and see what the situation was if
we if we left the European Union without
a deal we would want to see how markets
and businesses and consumers responded
to that and then as any responsible
government would we would take
appropriate fiscal measures to protect
the economy to prepare us for the future
and to strike out in a new direction
that would ensure that Britain was able
to succeed whatever the circumstances we
found ourselves in and of course it
wouldn't only be us as the government it
would also be the Bank of England
responsible for monetary policy that
would be looking at that situation and
taking action to
protect the economy even if we get a
deal or we can be worse off after
braixen
my job is to make sure that we're better
off and we go on getting better off
we've had you know for 200 years with a
few with a few intervening periods we've
had 200 years in which our living
standards have consistently raised over
my lifetime people's living standards
have almost doubled we want to go on
seeing that growth in living standards
so that we can make good on our promise
to the next generation that they too
will be better off than their parents
okay and now some people in your party
have been a bit scathing about your
attitude towards brexit and Boris
Johnson describing the Treasury is the
enemy of remain and you've also been
described as eel I mean are you a bit
gloomy about breakfast is that fair
no I don't think so at all I think what
we've done is the Treasury has done as a
department at the center of government
has taken the decision of the British
people and sought to deliver it
implement it in a way that protects our
economy protects living standards and
delivers on all the many other things
that the British people want because yes
people went out in their millions to
express an opinion on this very
important issue
but if you go and ask them whether this
is the most important issue to them many
of them will tell you no I'm concerned
about policing about education about the
health service about my own of course
and that's what I'm saying our job is to
take the instruction of the British
people on brexit and to ensure that we
deliver it in a way that also allows us
to go on delivering what they want to
see on health services on education on
police on defence on the environment and
all the other things that they regard as
very important to them and just finally
do you think you're able to be perhaps a
little bit more honest when it comes to
brexit and some of your cabinet
colleagues because you're perhaps the
only person sitting around the table who
doesn't fancy the job as Prime Minister
well I hope I'm always honest I always
try to be honest sometimes gets me into
a bit of trouble from some of my
advisers but I always try to be honest I
always try to answer the
that I'm asked because actually I think
one of the ways in which we rebuild
faith and confidence in politics is by
politicians trying to be honest with
people about the really big challenges
that we face do you think some of your
other party members should be a bit more
honest
well I'm sure all my colleagues are very
honest with you all the time Sophie yes
and I'm sure they'd all be delighted to
come and sit in this chair and be
equally honest and open with you and
Chancellor thank you very much thank you